so here's what the index annotation
looks like if we only want the city to
be indexed if it's not the default city
so at index and then we add if not
default dot class then the index the
property name which is City and then
here we just specify the default value
which is default City and if the city is
created without a value it's going to
get the default City as its value and
it's not going to be indexed we can
actually also see that in the admin
console on localhost here's two
conferences that I created and you can
see it tells us that they're not indexed
even though these two our index because
they have values these two conferences
are not indexed so I encourage you to
explore the documentation in objectify
to learn about different ways to
conditional eyes how you can index your
properties